you'll have to raise a rib
operating on yourself for little wounds
if you have anesthesia doable with
mirrors I've done it a couple of times
on myself hi I'm Peter Reed I'm a trauma
surgeon for about 30 years and I also
served about 24 years with the United
States Navy and back to look at more
battle wound scenes in movies and judge
how real they are
I give him a lot of points for the way
that he dropped and that's what almost
everybody does in real life is when you
get shot you just drop it wasn't these
dramatic Hollywood type of blown back
from a little handgun type of thing I'm
going to take away points for how big
the wounds are a sniper usually uses a
bolt action hunting type of rifle about
three three tenths of an inch in
diameter if you shoot them it'll make a
tiny hole I had one guy who was Sentry
Marine Corps it was from the sniper of
ramadi and we did a thoracotomy on him
so he bled out his entire cavity into
the chest but the entry and exit tiny
little hole no blood on the skin
covering fire
they didn't waste time they just dragged
them out of there he's not moving his
arms and legs so he could have had the
spinal cord but the trajectory looks
like it did not because right there from
that the moulash is a little more the
trapezius muscles rather than the
carotids overall
you know what I was criticizing was too
small and minor I'll give this a seven
she's way past yo who's next over here
sir Colonel Moody sir now sir yeah most
of our tents look like that the Marine
Corps started doing this early in my
career we started outfitting those
things and deciding all the little
instruments and gauzes that we were
going to put into it and then the Army
has these tents that put together and
you can make bigger and bigger spaces
but they had like very nice fabricated
metal shelves in there and things like
that those things are not available
W do the abdomen let's stabilize until
we get him to an old war give me some
wet bandages and an occlusive dressing
scope an et2 but it's in debate so you
know it looks like it's a triage area
but what I didn't like right away he
starts barking orders too that woman
behind him he's talking to her like
she's this uh assistant and she's got
her own patient and then what he has is
a GSW to the abdomen which is our
gunshot wound uh to the Torso to the
abdomen itself and then the lady tells
you that she's got an emergent Airway
that she has to do very rare from trauma
unless you got facial injuries
sandstorms ordered a smooth back but
we'll take your GSW in the APC
where are we going so not very realistic
when I was in Iraq when we got
sandstorms there were pretty bizarre
stuff that that would come in and what
you do is you hang tight don't drive
stay indoors doesn't make sense to me
that they're gonna take everybody there
in that situation and scenario get into
apcs which is armored personnel carriers
and they just get into ambulances is all
it is by the time they load them into
the vehicles trust me it's going to take
well over an hour an hour and a half so
during that time period those patients
would be dying as well
so this is a common scenario where you
would get an IED when you're inside
these vehicles and you get blown up from
underneath they actually don't get
penetrating injuries you get blunt
trauma so when the guys come out the guy
has a lot of fragmentation injuries
I am smelling so much it would have
popped the finger right off say damn you
gotta turn the kid in
damn sure none of this makes sense he's
got an obvious neck injury which is high
priority so if they're dying to have
somebody with blood in their mouth this
would be a time to do it right there's
three things we worried about in the
neck that's a carotid artery your
trachea and your esophagus he's trying
to tell him to cut the arm off with a
tourniquet and he was fussing around
with a ring again life over Limb and
then he got plenty of tourniquets that's
an ambulance and he uses his web belt
from his uh pants that gives us a two
two out of ten
[Music]
I love this seat this wound was uh
created by a sharp stick eventually the
main thing is that it's going to get
infected wood is notorious for just
having all sorts of germs and bacteria
in it so getting it out reduces the
burden of the bacterial load and the
fungus load and everything else
foreign
I was freaking out here because it
looked like he's gonna burn his biceps
when we do electrocautery in the surgery
it's pretty brutal and we do actually
burn a lot of the tissue so I wouldn't
mind doing that if the skin holes were
bigger right but his skin holes are
usually tiny so it's not like he's got a
big gaping wound in the back when you
put gunpowder inside there I have no
experience on this whatsoever myself but
I'm just using my imagination that when
you light it it's going to go this way
not this way so you are going to cause
more tissue injury inside as well using
gunpowder to cauterize and also to
sterilize is theoretical but I think
that's pretty hokey I'd give this about
a four don't try this at home
the kids got an infected arm but he
seemed very bright in this in this scene
so he was very aware which is
unfortunate because uh he's going to get
the arm cut off while he's awake without
anesthesia of any type
it's all right
thank you
the little knife makes it look like one
slice and it's done it's not first you
gotta slice a fleshy tissue in the
forearm they've got muscles and stuff
inside protected by the bones can't use
a slicing type of knife to go through
the bone you gotta have a saw we use
what's called a giggly saw which is a
little cutting wire or we actually use a
saw the best sauce is a hacksaw but the
surgical saws are going to be okay
I've never caused that kind of pain
where I gave him something to bite on
normally what we do in that situation is
we open up the wounds and let it puss
out and they don't need to necessarily
amputate the arm but life over limb you
will amputate the arm in order to Save a
Life I'm assuming that he might have had
a fracture underneath it or they tried
to get it to heal and they couldn't
you'll have to raise a rib
operating on yourself for little wounds
if you have anesthesia doable with
mirrors I've done it a couple of times
on myself they even did that in the
1800s the issue that I have with this
particular clip was raising the rib if
you hit the rib it's very very painful
the ribs are extremely sensitive
hi sir she'll patch up nicely and what
he's really doing is going after the
bullet we normally don't take out all
the bullets that we find if it's easily
palpable and we can find it's in soft
tissue then we'll we'll plug them out
but most of the bullets do okay in the
body but in the movies they always make
it look like it so if you get the blood
out you'll live and if you don't take
the bull out you'll die I'd give this a
good seven or eight out of ten
it's good it's good overall they're
pouring sulfur on it it is an antibiotic
it's an antibacterial if you've got a
fractured leg you've got a gash or a
wound if you put sulfur on it it helps
it doesn't really stop the bleeding it
wasn't meant to be a hemostatic agent as
we call it
you keep saying you remember shot in the
spine that's so smart to him to say that
and if he is he's paralyzed paralyzed
legs won't kill him but if he's bleeding
a lot and the spinal injuries to bleed a
lot that's what's going to kill him
[Music]
the medic he knows that he's paralyzed
and that's why he says check for a hole
in the back and if it's big enough to be
the acorn like he says that means that
it was probably an exit it really makes
a huge difference whether it's a handgun
or if it's a rifle the guns that they
used to use in World War II that Germany
had there were two kinds one was from a
rifle and a machine gun which are these
large bullets which are very fast but
they'll make tiny little holes actually
on the on the entry but in the exit
they'll blow it out they carry
submachine guns the bullet coming out of
there is no more no different than a
handgun so those will typically not
create as much of an exit if it's a
rifle when it goes out the back it's a
large hole and it's also called a
cavitation wound overall I'd give this a
an 8 out of 10.
Italian a but he got an open death wall
the blood pouring through the pressure
bandage I think he's got a lacerated
aorta he diagnosed that because the
dressings are bleeding that he's got a
hole in the aorta it could be coming
from anywhere
if he came in with a hole that you could
fit your hand into then you can go in
there and manually compress the aorta
blindly at whatever area that you want
to so
he's going to take a knife and make the
skin incision bigger but you can't get
your hand in between the ribs you have
to actually split the muscle all the way
front to back on the ribs in order to
get a retractor which is a vice reverse
Vise that splits your ribs open so we
can get into the chest cavity so we can
put a clamp on your aorta
when you put a clamp on the aorta he's
right if you do it too long your
ordinance below the uh clamp will die
but it preserves the blood from above
the clamp to your heart and brain alive
step through get his head and shoulders
flat right on the floor later we're
gonna need more ice when they cool him
from the bucket of ice that's called
external passive cooling where you let
the heat go from your body to the ice
and melt the ice that takes a long time
to cool the core so it's a waste of time
you have to do what's called active
internal cooling you can only do with
pump or something to go to every cell in
your brain every cell in your heart
every cell in your body and that's a
very efficient way to exchange heat
here's the ground
stick and piece of aorta from another
person into him that will give you maybe
three or four days before that blows out
because it's not your aorta it's not
been matched in when it's the wrong
transplant it will blow out and uh and
you'll die from a feasibility medical
standpoint this is like a one and a half
to two appears to be lodged between is a
femur and a muscle
we're on our way up right now okay so
pause here for a second who put those
clamps on there okay and what are they
clamping and where did they get the
X-ray from how did he notice it was her
x-ray by the way the x-ray of a little
old lady with hardly any soft tissue and
uh has no fracture so you got a 20
millimeter unexploded ordinance in her
leg what there's a four meter blast
radius
any movement could set it off he acts
like this is going to be a you know a
fusing of a bomb that if you hit the
wrong fuse it's going to go up this is a
20 millimeter 20 millimeters are what
they use in Vulcan guns uh in Gatling
guns on helicopters and airplanes you
know
f-22s f-18s these things are highly
stable even the high explosive ones so
when they hit a tank then they will
fragment and explode but pulling them
out of a leg is not going to cause an
explosion clamping
and that's around not a projectile
they've got his casing still in the back
it's only the projectile that would
comes out of the barrel and those blue
gloves are not sterile the blue gloves
are just disposable gloves they don't
have hats on masks on they're doing this
in the lobby or somewhere like that and
I worked in Los Angeles in that ER for
five years and I started the Navy trauma
Training Center there and the lobby
never looked that nice to me
this is hemorrhaging
in the military in a situation where
there's an actual explosive in the body
we will set them off to the side outside
of the facility where no one's going to
get hurt take care of everybody that
needs to get taken care of urgently
emergently get a team of volunteers to
go out there they put a stronghold
around them and then do the thing for
the metal that they're going to get in a
civilian setting none of this makes any
sense I give this a a zero out of 10.
it'd be okay if he didn't uh say there
was an artery but didn't look like it
was bleeding much at all and there was
not a swelling or a hematoma underneath
it so from a medical standpoint of all
of this that wound there won't kill them
and then his sewing the techniques were
not good the civilians have a tendency
to try to use on the movies the ringed
forceps the ringed instruments and the
thumb and then the first finger is
usually for your fourth finger you
control the rest of the instruments with
the other two
doesn't tie a knot and he bites it off
when you sew you could do a running
Stitch which is fast but then he bites
off and then leaves that thing down
without tying at least the knot so
that's going to unravel yeah just below
my floating rib you're sure
be sure not to graze Michael that's a
little too medial for me he hit him
right in the clavic up here if he goes
into classical it can be very
problematic and then you get a little
lower you can get a lot of nerves Choice
locations are okay
medical wise obviously he did such a bad
job at doing that up there I give it a
five five out of ten that's gonna do any
good until we get that Arrow out of them
good
so that doesn't make any sense to me the
arrow if he got shot front to back it
has already caused the damage where it
resides so why would you pull it out the
other side the only time I would pull it
through is if it's a Target arrow and it
doesn't have a tip and there's feathers
in the back that you can't pull out now
that's got a razor tip to it if it went
front and didn't come all the way out to
the back it didn't pierce the skin it is
already injured what is going to injure
just pull it out the front why cause
more injuries by cutting him surgically
and then cutting more muscle you just go
get it again first oh wow distilled
Spirits is 40 so it has some
antibacterial properties you won't get
any contaminants into whether you use
rum vodka gin whiskey bourbon it doesn't
matter I give this a 4 out of 10 Max
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click on the link above
foreign